he orders up everybody's procedure my
Luigi here inside of The Witcher 3 and
in this video I'm going to be showing
you guys how you can reset all of your
skill points in your swordplay and signs
and alchemy if you accidentally put
something in sub place you don't want to
do I'm going to show you a potion that
you can find and drink and then it will
erase all of your skill points and let
you put them where you want so as you
saw I just fast traveled to a little
town called mid Rose it is south it is
south west
yeah southwest of crows perch where you
have the bloody bear and all that stuff
and you don't want to go to an alchemy
shop but just north and to the right so
north east of this town now at this
alchemy shop it's gonna be a Kurt Chris
I forget but it's an ad it's alchemy
it's a witch I think it's a witch a
sorceress that you have side quests and
main quest actually in the game
Kristin Mertz I actually think it is so
you're gonna go up to her and she's
gonna be selling the potion for actually
kind of a lot of money it's gonna be a
thousand crowns like is the currency
it's gonna be a thousand so that is a
kind of expensive for potion there are
other alchemy shops that sell this
however they are far and few in between
there's not that many of them honestly
it's kind of a rare sight to see this
potion alchemy shop so this is the best
place I know confirmed that has this
potion so you're gonna see in the bottom
of the inventory is gonna be the I
forget what it's called but it's going
to be the potion as you can see the
potion of clearance it cost a thousand
crown and you see I only have 1400
crowns so I'm not gonna buy in this
video since I'm not too worried I don't
really care to reset my skills at the
moment but you guys can see right there
there it is plain clear as day that
potion will reach all your skills so
that you can put them in whichever order
you want if you want to change up or
play style you want to change up your
build so hope you guys have enjoyed this
video I actually grabbed little
saltpeter since I haven't been able to
find and I really need it for some
alchemy stuff I hope you guys enjoyed
this video I'm going to put them more
with your content so you can look at my
channel
that and yeah it's basically the video I
hope you enjoy the tip and peace out
guys